Karen Voght, founder and CEO of Wellness Incorporated...
...and creator of the Alphabet Fitness program, gets kids on their feet to learn their ABCs.
Being a literacy champion is an honor to me.
What we see are children sitting more and more nowadays...
...and little children in the age range that we're working with, three to six-year olds,...
...they are designed to move.
That's how they strengthen and develop their full body and their brains together.
We just simply let them go and learn their ABCs by mimicking these 26 chimp letters...
...and then starting to write the words together as a group.
We have so much obesity and stress in our world...
...that simply stretching their body when they're learning their ABCs....
...reduces their stress levels and makes them receptive children.